[Musica]
siete mai andati in vacanza una volta
nella vostra vita una io ci sono andato
poche volte e l'ultima se non sbaglio è
stata a maggio di quest'anno soldato a
madrid è successa una cosa curiosa
madrid come in tutte le grandi città
anzi non solo le grandi città come in
tutte le città del mondo c'è un fenomeno
che conosciamo che quello delle persone
che chiedono la carita alle persone che
fanno mendicante diciamo e qual è il
sistema comunicativo che utilizzano i
mendicanti e per chiederci soldi non sto
parlando di una questione sociale scappi
temi sto parlando di un sistema di
comunicazione fanno leva sostanzialmente
su due cose la prima è la il nostro
senso di colpa
ci troviamo in una strada ricca piena di
negozi e loro sono persone che hanno
problemi anno hanno dei problemi anche
fisici che ci mostrano pensateci
ci sono delle persone che mostrano i
deficit fisici per chiedere alla nostra
carità quindi fanno effetto al nostro
senso di colpa e fanno effetto alla
nostra sulla nostra carità persone che
non hanno gambe non hanno le mani e ci
chiedono i soldi noi quindi sappiamo
oggettivamente che hanno bisogno non lo
supponiamo lo sappiamo ma non gli diamo
i soldi perché mettiamo generalmente in
atto iii protezioni la prima è io glieli
darei però se vi do lui vi devo dare a
tutti non posso uscire con 100 euro la
mattina per tali a tutti
la seconda è io gli darei
ma dietro c'è un racket se li do a lui
poi il suo aguzzino glieli prende e
rimanda questa persona a fare la carità
la terza è questa persona potrebbe
andare a lavorare a due spalle così in
campagna a pomodori c'è sempre bisogno e
non glieli dai a madrid stavo camminando
su una strada che si chiama gran via chi
è stato in spagna la conosce una strada
notevolmente ricca bella raffinata piena
di negozi
ho visto un clochard per terra seduto
che non faceva assolutamente nulla e ho
visto le persone che gli davano i soldi
io mi sono avvicinato
e ho continuato a vedere persone dagli
soldi e lui non faceva nulla allora ho
pensato questo è il sacro graal della
comunicazione
se io capisco cosa sta facendo lui io
divento ricco senza far nulla
mi sono avvicinato mentre mi avvicinavo
un ragazzo addirittura non solo gli ha
dato i soldi giuro ho visto con i miei
occhi ero con la mia compagna a gli ha
dato i soldi ha sorriso gli ha dato la
mano prima di andar via e non ho capito
niente della vita
avvicinandomi ho notato che aveva una
cosa semplice banale quasi aveva davanti
a sé tre bussolotti tre scatole in una
sera scritto quello che mettete qua va
in birra quello che mettete qua va in
vino quello che mettete qua va in whisky
sta ridendo tutti il riso quale ho detto
che figata questa qua ma sai che io
adesso la bella birra me la farei
ho dato i soldi per comprarsi la birra
di fatto ammazzandolo perché se lui fa
davvero quello che dice che farebbe con
quei soldi io lo sto ammalando di
cirrosi
allora ho cominciato a riflettere ho
cominciato a riflettere con forza su
questo fatto ma perchè gli ho dato i
soldi perché a gente senza gambe non
glieli do e metto in atto delle dei
meccanismi a lui glieli ho dati poi ho
capito
ogni volta che noi facciamo qualcosa lo
facciamo per noi non lo facciamo per gli
altri lo facciamo per noi e anche per
gli altri ogni volta che facciamo del
bene ed è meraviglioso lo facciamo
perché ci fa stare bene e fa anche stare
bene gli altri a questo aggiungo lui il
clochard non mi ha chiesto nulla era
seduto e mi ha fatto ridere mi ha dato
qualcosa non mi ha chiesto mi ha fatto
ridere mi ha dato un imprinting positivo
una percezione positiva e quindi visto
che non mi ha chiesto io gli ho dato
se questa cosa arrivato a 44 anni non
l'avevo mai pensata prima ho pensato
quante sono le cose online che ci
capitano tutti i giorni che noi non
siamo in grado di valutare il mondo
dell'online non c'era dieci anni fa la
vita online è ormai comune per tutti non
si può neanche più dire
cheva add on line siamo line
costantemente un italiano usa google 30
volte al giorno mediamente un millennio
guarda al telefono 250 volte al giorno
senza notifiche provate a immaginare con
quanta con quante le volte lo guarda con
le notifiche quindi è evidente che
accadono cose online che noi non siamo
in grado di interpretare perché dieci
anni fa non c'erano mancano regole
educative comuni vi faccio un esempio su
tutti avete mai sentito di questa parola
che ho messo in inglese perché in
ferrarese non si può sentire quando dico
dizzy bee nizione online la gente
riguarda invece mark online disinibisce
di fatto si tratta di questo le persone
tendono a fare alcune persone non tutte
tendono a fare di più e più spesso
online piuttosto che offline
e se questo vale un po per tutti c'è un
altro fenomeno legato a questo a questo
particolare è concetto che è curioso
quando noi discutiamo con qualcuno
offline
attacchiamo qualcuno offline ne
soffriamo sappiamo stress nell'attaccare
qualcuno quando questo accade online
no ma se veniamo attaccati offline
subiamo uno stress se veniamo attaccati
online subiamo uno stress quindi vedete
che c'è una differenza sostanziale ecco
perché c'è il fenomeno degli haters ecco
perché alcune persone molte in molto in
vista in italia sui social donne in
particolare vengono attaccate con frasi
di una brutalità e di una violenza che
nella vita reale non esisterebbero non è
l'impunità e questo fenomeno
siamo in un mondo nuovo è un fatto e non
importa che cosa ne pensate
è un fatto è un mondo nuovo
c'è bisogno di regole nuove
se ha bisogno di regole nuove perché noi
non siamo in grado di interpretare
quello che ci ha caldi fianco quello che
ci accade attorno
che cosa sta succedendo quindi io mi
sono trovato a pensare prima ho bisogno
di un assioma ho bisogno di un'area
macro regola come la relatività di
einstein che metta d'accordo ogni tipo
di cosa ogni tipo di attività contenuto
persona evento che accade un
nella mia ricerca mi sono imbattuto in
un libro che consiglio a tutti perché
incredibilmente bello che si chiama in
un milione di piccoli pezzi di james
frey tratta di un ragazzo che esce dal
tunnel di tutte le dipendenze che
esistono su questa terra facendo uno
sforzo immane
vi voglio raccontare di questa frase
incredibile che ho letto in questo libro
che è curati di quanto dicono gli altri
e sarai sempre loro prigioniero io
quando l'ho letta ho pensato ho trovato
il mantra io non posso curarmi di quello
che dicono gli altri
altrimenti divento quello che gli altri
vogliono se comincio a sbatter man e di
quello che gli altri dicono di me on
line sono un uomo libero
contemporaneamente ho trovato questa
frase di sigmund non ripeto il cognome
perché tanto non ce la farei mai
sputerei evidentemente agli psicologi
tedeschi si chiamano tutti così la frase
ragazzi e incredibile la vita umana si è
sempre svolta in gruppi la leggo perché
non voglio sbagliare condividere
costituisce un elemento essenziale
dell'esperienza nessuno e salute mentale
e compatibile senza di questo non
possiamo non curarsi degli altri perché
se no non siamo sani di mente allora
vedete che andiamo in corto circuito
abbiamo detto bellissima la frase di
frey per essere libero non me ne devo
curare ma non posso non curarsene
ma allora che cosa devo fare
devo ascoltare tutto quello che mi viene
detto e devo somatizzarlo o non
ascoltare nessuno voi riconoscete in
questa foto una persona che lava una
macchina
bello no tre anni fa ho avuto un
incidente in auto è un camion per i
trasporti eccezionali mi ha investito
nella verità non mi sono fatto nulla ma
la macchina si è completamente distrutta
allora il giorno dopo sui social è fatto
una provocazione ironica ho scritto un
post nel quale dicevo quest'anno ho
scritto il mio primo libro
sto bene in giacca o presentato dagli
eventi fichissimi ho fatto il giro
d'italia tutte cazzate di questo tipo
e alla fine ho scritto non è possibile
che non esista una casa automobilistica
che non mi regali una macchina non è
giusto è il primo esperimento italiano
di crowd funding personale detto anche
scrocca gio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
la mattina dopo con mio assoluto
sconcerto mi chiama una casa
automobilistica e mi dicono abbiamo
sentito abbiamo letto il suo messaggio
vorremmo regalarle una macchina io al
telefono ho risposto e la fregatura dove
sta cosa devo fare
cioè mi date anche delle pentole da
pagare cosa come funziona mi danno un
auto e ovviamente il mondo del web
un'auto con un'asta che sulla fiancata
una macchina per rudy fate le persone mi
chiedevano ma chi era un di una persona
con dei problemi con no sono sono io si
è una persona con dei problemi il ferro
il web italiano si è spaccato da una
parte quelli che dicevano rudy bandiera
è un genio da quel dall'altra parte
dell'indice me loro di vendere un matto
dall'altra parte quell'edizione rudy
bandiera un ladro perché questa la
questa mattina l'avrebbero potuta dare a
una onlus invece di darla lui c'era
gente che dicevano di bandiera e ricco
se la doveva comprare mia moglie leggeva
queste cose diciamo ha davvero sei ricco
ve lo giuro gente che diceva brutta vita
tremende nei miei confronti io mi sono
trovato una sera non sto scherzando a
piangere ho 44 anni a piangere per
quello che gente mi diceva senza
conoscermi allora ho riflettuto ma
perché perché mi giudicavano non
giudicavano il fatto giudicavano me
senza conoscermi allora lì ho capito
tutto ho capito che io devo ascoltare
tutto quello che dicono gli altri
quando il motore da cui sono mossi non è
il risentimento non è la rabbia non è
l'invidia e non è il giudizio
noi non possiamo giudicare quello che
non conosciamo
possono dire rudy bandiera ha fatto una
bellissima cosa possono dire lo di
bandiera ha fatto una bruttissima cosa
possono dire sa parlare non sa parlare è
furbo e intelligente e brutto ha la
barba ispida ma non possono giudicarmi
come individuo questo è il primo assioma
dobbiamo ascoltare tutti coloro che non
giudicano perché un line è facilissimo
punta del dito giudicare è facilissimo e
noi dobbiamo liberarci da questa cosa
oltre a l'assioma ho pensato a sette
regole e siccome sono un genio creativo
lo chiamate le sette regole
avevo pensato di chiamarle le otto
regole e metterne 7 allora lì sì che
sarei stato davvero brillante ma mi
sembrava già sufficiente fare questa
idiozia
l'assioma l'abbiamo capito il giudizio
il problema le regole sono queste regola
numero uno ragazzi il mezzo è contenuto
sempre di più e lo sarà sempre di più
noi siamo quello che gli altri
percepiscono quindi noi siamo quello che
comunichiamo non credete a chi vi dice
l'abito non fa il monaco
lo fa dannatamente il vincere sempre a
tutti i costi non è essere vincenti
essere arroganti
non dobbiamo umiliare le persone con le
quali comunichiamo su facebook twitter
linkedin per vincere in una discussione
vincere solo vincere sempre e arrogante
devi stare lucido e concentrato su chi
hai di fronte
pensate rskype quante volte vi è
successo di fare delle call skype
quante volte sentite quello dell'altra
parte che scrive sulla tastiera fa
incassare da morire stai parlando con me
lo stai parlando con qualcun'altro
lucidi e concentrati sulla persona che
avete di fronte in quel momento è la
persona più importante della vostra
esistenza non devi calpestare b per
andare da aaa a c
oggi mettiamo tutto sul piatto del
risultato
se ho un risultato sono bravo non è vero
se hai fatto un percorso dignitoso non
umiliante per nessuno che ti ha portato
un risultato sei bravo se non sei un
perdente
dobbiamo riprendere in mano il discorso
delle brave persone
dobbiamo far tornare di moda essere
brave persone chissenefrega dei
risultati da soli
viviamo in un mondo con altre persone
non è il mio risultato che migliora
tutto il resto è il percorso che ho
fatto per raggiungerlo non sei obbligato
a parte
ci pare a tutte le discussioni
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che la settimana scorsa ho trovato uno
che ha scritto quello che penso io vale
quello che pensi tu ma chi l'ha detto
se si sta parlando di social e di
tecnologia e tu fai il chirurgo scusa ma
il tuo giudizio non è come il mio se si
sta parlando di medicina e tu fai il
chirurgo io faccio il muratore al mio
giudizio non è come il tuo non devi per
forza dire la tua
ascolta stai zitto ogni tanto hai una
responsabilità verso tutti i ragazzi
noi dobbiamo individuare nella nostra
testa questa immagine se tu andavi nel
bar e dicevi una cassata la gente
attorno ti dicevo taci che pagavano una
spuma e ti mandavano a casa
oggi non è più così tu puoi influenzare
migliaia di individui ogni giorno della
tua vita devi esserne responsabile
non deve esserne responsabile la
piattaforma tu sei responsabile
sei sempre in pubblico anche quando sei
in privato capita sempre più spesso che
le conversazioni private arrivino in
pubblico è una cosa per nulla da
sottovalutare le comunicazioni che
avvengono online sempre più spesso
avvengono in canali privati gruppi
chiusi gruppi segreti chat
voi dovete pensare che quello che
scrivete qui può uscire
non è bello non è giusto ma può accadere
guardate tutti i casi di cyber bullismo
ma anche i casi delle banche che sono
capitato ultimamente i dati sono nostri
sono importantissimi ma fate molta
attenzione a quello che scrivete
anche se in privato e poi ho fatto una
considerazione anche secondo me è
piuttosto interessante che è questa l'ho
chiamata la teoria delle cerchie
ristrette perché mi piace dare dire che
si costruiscono delle teorie non importa
quello che fai o ci sei diventato non
importa come ti vedono gli altri i tuoi
amici di vecchia data
ti vedranno sempre comunque come il
solito pirla con amore benevolenza
dolcezza ma un pirla io ho scritto tre
libri l'ultimo l'ho scritto con la casa
editrice più importante d'italia
mia moglie non ha letto nessuno dei miei
libri li ha sul comodino è c'è stata una
volta che l'ho chiesto ma schifo perché
non li legge ma ha detto ma lei ti
conosco da una vita siamo insieme da una
vita
sto con te lo so che cosa pensi
i miei amici con cui faccio aperitivo
tutti i venerdì sera lo faccio da
vent'anni tutti i venerdì sera
alcuni li conosco da trent'anni hanno
tutti i miei libri nessuno e ha detto 1
allora io mi sono chiesto perché ho
cominciato a chiedere a loro e loro
hanno cominciato a dirmi ma sei dai ma
dai team della risposta
sapete il motivo il motivo è semplice
per loro
rudy bandiera è quello delle grigliate
quello delle sbronze al venerdì sera è
quello del dai andiamo a mangiare il
pesce al mare è quello del dai facciamo
un lan party domenica 40 anni rudy
bandiera è quello che fa da sempre
queste cose con loro quindi vi voglio
lasciare con tre riflessioni molto
semplici da te come trussardi madrid sul
web date informazioni utili oggettive
funzionali
ricordate di occuparvi di quello che
dicono gli altri solo se non vi
giudicano e rimanete per i vostri amici
degli amabili pirla
[Musica]
e adesso farò un self quindi vi prego
sorridente siate felici e viva grazie vi
voglio bene
[Applauso]
grazie
[Musica]
un atto grazie grazie